Je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps je veux acheter
des choses pour un ami bien sûr tu
dois avoir des pantalons oui nous les
avons en silicone et en nylon cette dame mesure 5
pieds 5 et taille zéro donc je suis comme 2 paires
en soie
avez-vous une chemise et de la soie qui correspondent,
nous avons un bon outil à main quelle est la main
c'est ce que vous cherchez vous
choisissez le meilleur matériau sunnite ces
jours-ci vient de Milan et comment il se
plie se sent bien
que diriez-vous d'un  quelques paires de porte-jarretelles
dans les mêmes couleurs
vous devriez porter des bas je porte des
bas qui me ressemblent à des collants eh bien
ce n'est pas des soutiens-gorge
elle ne porte pas de soutiens-gorge elle ressemble
à une femme très intéressante depuis combien de temps la
connaissez-vous  trois jours trois jours
et tu achètes des sous-vêtements pour son
emballage cadeau ceux-ci pour moi si tu
transmettras désolé dix-sept sont un beau
t-shirt très facile c'est pourquoi tu es si
profond avec le suspect ou avec la victime